Is there any other way to clean the eye and pro wave other than the periodic acid that was recommended by true life?
It is toxic and since we live in an apartment, there's no healthy way to use it.
Yeah, I understand that and I understand that that's a problem to be honest.
I would like to see a raise of hands of every one of our patients that uses the eye and pro wave on a regular basis and that actually do clean it.
I would suspect it's probably less than half the people.
We've had people that have used it at up to 80 times and have never cleaned it once.
The cleaning of it is probably more necessary for people with maybe dirty or water.
I haven't done any investigation on it. I don't know if people with chloride and fluoride in their water
mainly regular city water or build up on the eye and pro wave plates or people that are using it
with in a floral setting with a more harder water like for well water or something.
It says I just rinse the eye and pro wave with hot water and never use verionic acid over a year.
Yeah, I would guess that more people fall in its category too that they're not using the verionic acid.
But I do, we have had some people that have had issues with their eye and pro wave
and I think it has to do with the hardest of their water or something because they had built up quite quickly on it.
I cleaned my monthly well water with a softer you going on 18 months now.
Okay, so you cleaned it with verionic acid, patty or you cleaned it just with your well water
rinsed it like it is. Oh, with the acid. Okay, okay, so we'll come back to Mark's question.
Well, it's this ties to the low-dose gel trexone. That was me using the low-dose gel trexone.
I started at 1 milligram February and as of today, I just went to 3 milligrams max of 4.5.
All the H is lower by a lot and inflammation much lower.
With right. So I would, you know, I think the pathway there is if the person has
chronic inflammation from some other source using low-dose gel trexone can call that down and
that could possibly. So going back to this question here again. So if you're going to use low-dose
gel trexone with mistletoe, I would say spread them out. If you're doing mistletoe injections,
you know, every, you know, day then maybe at the, you know, 12 hour point, then use the low-dose
trexone. Typically low-dose gel trexone is dosed at night before you go to bed any house. If you're
doing the mistletoe in the morning to stimulate an immune response and you're using the low-dose
gel trexone to kind of clear out the inflammation at the end of the day, then I guess it makes sense
then. And I can see the efficacy of that, especially if your, if your cancer is tied to some chronic
inflammatory source in the, in the beginning, that I could see that how you could tie that together
and you could make a case for that.